why
the public education is such a root of
moral evil for you well because it now
says that there's one
standard and that standard is determined
by government by by a bureaucracy by by
whatever the government deems is in the
national interest and bismarck's very
explicit about this he's training the
workers of the future uh you know they
they need to catch up and and you know
with england and other places and they
need to train the workers and there's
going to be a he's going to train some
people to be the managerial class he's
going to train other people to be and he
decides right the the government the
bureaucracy is going to decide who's who
and where they go there's no individual
choice there's no individual uh
showing an ability to break out of what
what the government has decided is their
little box uh there's very little
freedom there's very little
you know ultimately there's very little
competition there's very little
innovation and this is the problem we
have today in american education which
we can get to is there's no competition
and no innovation we have one
standard fit all and then we have
conflicts about what should be taught
and the conflicts now not pedagogical
they're not about what works and what
doesn't
nobody cares about that it's about
political agendas right it's about what
my group wants to be taught and what
that group wants to be taught rather
than actually discovering how do we get
kids to read i mean we all know how to
get kids to eat but there's a political
agenda about not teaching phonics for
example
so
a lot of schools don't teach phonics
even though the kids will never learn
how to read properly so it becomes
politics and i i don't believe politics
belongs in education i think education
is a product it's a service
and we know how to deliver products and
services really really efficiently at a
really really low price
at a really really high quality and
that's leaving it to the market to do
but your fundamental criticism is that
the state can use education
to uh further authoritarian
ames well or whatever the aims did i
mean think about the conservative today
critique of american educational system
it's dominated by the left yeah what did
you expect
right if you leave it if you leave it up
to the state to fund they're going to
fund the things that promote
state growth and state intervention and
the left is better at that it has been
better at that than the right and and
they now dominate our educational
institutions
you